قال منسق الشؤون الانسانيه المؤقت في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله جيمس مكولك ان
اسرائيل تمنع دخول العديد من المواد
الطبيه الى غزه وكشف ان اسرائيل اضافت
اقلام انسولين الاطفال الى قائمه المواد
المحظوره مؤخرا وانه لا يعرف سبب هذا
القرار هناك مجموعه كامله من البضائع
الممنوعه ونستمر في تقديم القوائم الى
السلطات الاسرائيليه للحصول على موافقتهم
وبعضها عباره عن مواد طبيه مثل الادويه
الاساسيه والمواد اللازمه لعلاج الصدمات
والامراض المزمنه احد الامثله على ذلك هو
انه تم مؤخرا ادراج الاقلام المستخدمه
لانسولين الاطفال في تلك القائمه وفيما
يتعلق بالاسباب لا استطيع حقا ان اشرحها
لانني لا اعرف نجري حاليا مناقشات مع
السلطات الاسرائيليه في كيفيه فحص تلك
القائمه التي يعتقدون انها مواد محظوره
وايجاد طرق تمكننا من الحصول على موافقه
لانها ستكون سلعا اساسيه بالنسبه لنا
لمعالجه حالات الطوارئ التي تتكشف حاليا
بطريقه دراماتيكيه للغايه في
غزه